here now to respond stephen miller
former senior advisor and director of
speech writing
to president trump stephen thank you for
being here tonight so first cpac is
always something that conservatives look
forward to lots of big things happen
there every single year
just your reaction to the first day
thank you for having me on
well i think what you heard today at
cpac was a very optimistic
forward-looking vision for the
republican party and i think what you're
going to see
on sunday when the president speaks is
he's going to outline
that same optimistic vision like only he
can
and give a concrete detailed plan for
how the republican party is going to win
the midterms
in two years and take back the white
house in four years there's been a lot
of talk of president trump's speech is
the first big speech he's going to give
after he has left office you brought up
2022
what is his message what does what does
he think that republicans should be
doing on the campaign trail
to stop this barrage from the left now
that they have full control in
washington
well he's going to outline a blue collar
working class
conservative populism that stands up to
china
stands up to big tech stands up to the
donor class
and stands for working people and one of
the big contrasts he's going to draw
of course is on the immigration fiasco
that is happening before our very eyes
right now
when donald trump left office we had the
most secure
border in american history it was safe
it was under control drugs were being
kept out
illegal immigration was being kept down
and the whole hemisphere benefited as a
result
in just four weeks joe biden has created
a humanitarian catastrophe
and the main victims of this catastrophe
are illegal immigrant youth who are
being smuggled to our country in record
numbers
because of joe biden's policies he did
that
that is because of his policy changes
and i
think it's morally reprehensible so on
the issue we'll get to the illegal
immigration bit in just a second because
you're an expert on that you've been
covering it for many many years and
we've watched this crisis come
and go and president trump implemented a
number of policies to make it stop and
now
it's back but in terms of what the
president thinks we need to focus on and
conservatives need to focus on
moving forward we heard a lot about a
civil war inside of the republican party
on the right but when i look at what
happened at cpac today
that's not what i see i see a bunch of
happy warriors coming together
with a number of principles that they
share they're trying to pin
the democrats as the party of elitists
the party of intolerance
and it seems to be working in a lot of
ways
i've got news for you the civil war the
republican party
is over it was waged four years ago when
donald trump won the nomination
those battles are done those fights are
behind us
the new working-class republican party
is here to stay it's not going anywhere
and this idea that we're going to bring
back chamber of commerce republicanism
is preposterous that's over with the
policies of endless wars
the policies of outsourcing the policies
of uncontrolled migration
the policies of catering to the donor
class that is the past
donald trump and his policies of a
working class party
that's the future and that is here for
the long haul
well you brought up the crisis of
illegal immigration that we are now
seeing
happening at the southern border we're
just a month into joe biden's new
administration
and we're already seeing that dhs is in
panic mode they are predicting that they
will have 13 000
unaccompanied minors come over the
border in may that's just a short number
of months from now you have the white
house press secretary now trying to
backtrack this idea that they're not
using shelters which they once called
concentration camps and now we're also
seeing which is the news of the day
that the biden administration is now
going to use taxpayer money
to fly unaccompanied minors at the
border to
family members or adults who are living
in the united states already and as
stephen you know
many of them are already here illegally
it is this is mind-boggling what the
body administration is doing
is they are effectively facilitating
illegal
child smuggling they are facilitating
illegal
human trafficking you have violent
cartels
that are taking young people illegally
across multiple countries and dropping
them off
at our border for the purpose of
delivering them into the interior of the
united states
and the us government is completing the
last leg
in the smuggling operation this is
heinous
under our administration when we left
office
we had a policy in place to humanely
reunite illegal immigrant youth with
their families back in their home
countries
in guatemala in el salvador in honduras
instead what the bible administration is
doing is keeping these youth from ever
going back to their home country
and relocating them in the united states
the message to the whole world is
anyone under the age of 18 can come here
illegally and stay
that is wholly unsustainable it is
reckless
and it is morally depraved so stephen
you know we always talk about fairness
and when it comes to
illegal immigration and what americans
are paying for and the burden to the
taxpayer
and now we're learning that these
shelters which again the left was
calling concentration camps when the
trump administration opened them as
overflow facilities
in 2019 we're hearing now that
unaccompanied minors are being
taught they are in schooling they're
being given an education
and yet we have schools all over the
country that are still closed because
joe biden is capitulating to
the teachers unions and giving in to
their extortion
uh your comments on that no it just the
it it's it's the shameless hypocrisy
of the left the idea that it's unsafe
for american students to go to school
but we're going to open schools on the
border for illegal alien youth from all
of planet earth
and here's the thing we all believe in
the humane treatment of people who cross
the border unlawfully
especially young people but let's be
very clear
a policy of releasing all illegal
immigrant youth into the country
on a functionally permanent basis is an
incentive for child smuggling it is a
reward for child smuggling
and its sole result will be an endemic
level of global
child smuggling and that is why i say it
is fundamentally immoral
it is wrong it is getting young people
badly hurt
and it's enriching criminal cartels that
prey
upon innocent people across the western
hemisphere and
this whole administration's policy
whether it's on energy
whether it's on the economy whether it's
on migration
joe biden's paying back his big wealthy
donors
instead of standing up for working
people and what you're going to see on
sunday
is donald trump stake his claim to being
the champion
of everyday hard-working citizens
especially those who have the least
well stephen miller we appreciate you
being here to preview former president
trump's cpac speech and of course to
talk about this crisis that we are now
seeing
unfold at the border which surely isn't
going to go away anytime soon thank you
so much
thank you